so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app i am
kelly stewart alongside your favorite
guy greg ivory
well i pointed the wrong way look let's
be honest cappy's not here today we're
gonna have a great time
greg do you ever get a vacation because
i sure don't ah
i don't think i don't i've went on
vacation in a while kelly so uh
kind of jealous kind of jealous all
right guys we're gonna pick our week 14
anytime touchdown squirt now we are nine
and four on the season greg not so bad
if you ask me not so bad not so bad at
all that's not true i'll take that
i'll take that i'll take that any day
you might end up on the rankings list
with a nine and
what is it nine and three nine and four
record
that means we're just coasting into the
playoffs last week we had tayson hill
our dude didn't only score one touchdown
he scored two touchdowns
for us thank you to riley sorbo and his
chickens for that pick
this week we asked you on br social
who's going to score a touchdown this
week
derek henry taysom hill dalvin cook dk
metcalf james robinson
ezekiel elliott wayne gallman
and carry on johnson
how did he who's we got to talk to the
producer how did he make the list
carry on johnson really
well greg we're about to find out we've
got five legendary pitches coming up for
you but first here are some of our
favorite videos you sent us
all right squad ride lock of the week
let's go
cook baby lock it in
what are we going for hines what what is
this
anytime touchdown store take some help
you know we rocking with tayson hill
this weekend let's take some hill
who dat nation noah baby
ah yes there's nothing like
waking up sunday morning and watching
squad ride videos that just put me in a
good mood kelly
that just put me in the giving mood and
it is
december it's christmas season so guess
what
i'm in the comments man giving away some
hoodies
looking for takes and takes only kp
giants winners only
with the please i like that i like that
that's not deserving of a hoodie though
but i'm gonna give ko ko tav
24 uh i butchered that but the the
producers are gonna get it
he said rob anderson for a touchdown
today
you're walking away with a hoodie
because i like that i like that i like
that a lot
uh br mikey locks carry on johnson carry
on johnson
i don't know wow kale bro 10 says
hopkins metcalf henry jefferson and
kelsey
he threw a parlay out there for us kelly
i like that he's also walking away with
a hoodie
i'm done with the comments kelly let's
get this show on the road
all right we're gonna put your videos
head to head and decide who this week's
squad ride
is greg tell everyone who is up first
up first my guy mike rotter
and we're calling him the conspiracy
legend
let's take a look at the video
you bet going right here l lions
drone 4 detroit 5 wins they lost to the
texans game's probably gonna be on the
radio
okay carry on johnson touchdown
ah okay okay interesting kelly
interesting i'll just leave it at that
up next we got my guy carter 22 backup
i hope this isn't his backup account but
uh we're gonna call him
the dart legend so let's take a look at
the video
all right we are betting we're going to
let the darts decide who i picked for
any time touchdowns for this week
up on the board we got travis kelsey
derek henry nick
chubb wayne gallman and just in case tom
brady if i missed by mile
[Music]
all right wayne gallman has a lock to
score a touchdown this week
wow wow wow wow one time
guy i see but let me talk about the
conspiracy legend kelly uh
i was with this guy i was with him i was
with him i was
riding with him until he said ariane
johnson
we just got done talking about it carry
on johnson are you
serious brother like uh he's spending
way too much time with his license plate
i'm done with that pick i mean that
video let me talk about the dart legend
kelly
did you see the sweatshirt
did you see that i saw that gang yes yes
he gets points for that he gets points
for that
but not only did he have the sweatshirt
not only did he
uh throw the dart and got it on goldman
in one try but let's talk about the pick
wayne goldman i
like it kelly plus 120 uh
the giant is taking on arizona talk to
me what are you what are you thinking
carry on johnson goldman talk to me
kelly
greg this is an interesting pick here
now
the reason why i'm gonna go with garmin
is because it only makes
sense we're gonna boost this from
draftkings
up to three to one i need you guys to
give me some like bigger
favorites now i know i don't ask for
bigger favorites very often but
plus 450 why would we want three to one
never mind
anyway as far as the pit goes i like the
giants here now i know this is a buy low
spot on the cardinals so a lot of people
are
rushing to back the cardinals here on
the road but this giants team has shown
a lot of promise over the last five
weeks
i think that they get the win at home i
like plus two and a half i even threw
them
in to a teaser oh kelly don't tell me
that i've been hearing cardinals all day
in my dms talking about take the points
all right all right all right what are
the commenters saying all right kelly
i'm in the comments can you believe
our guy cabbie's on vacation in the
comments i did see cabbie in the
comments um
you should give him a hoodie show show
kevin some love in the comments guys
all right here we go i got uh kelly
they're back and forth they're back and
forth brett
mcc 12 said wayne goldman 1 000 i mean
it's more than 1 000. he put like one
trillion percent
he's riding with wayne garman um i also
see uh there's a lot of gifts there's a
lot of gifts
kelly they're back with the gifts this
week um next one i'll call it next one
i'll call it
kp giants kp giant says
wayne goldman touchdown easy lock today
kelly with that being said we're moving
on
to the next round with the dart legend
and wayne gallman moving on all right
greg three rounds left let's start
round two who do you got for me at going
against the dart legend
kelly round two we got luke
barnes the coin toss legend
let's look at the video how's it going
today br betting we got two absolute
locks of anytime touchdown scores today
now we're going to let the coin decide
for us so we got heads austin eck large
instead of atlanta falcons d
we got tails for dk metcalf against that
new york jets d
all right here we go best of luck
and it is tails dk metcalf against that
atrocious new york justice lock it in
thank you beer betting
this guy his manners was on point kelly
let me just let me just break it down a
little bit
he had good manners he gave both conte
like
every both players he gave them an equal
chance at winning it was a 50 50 chance
my mom would love this guy i mean he he
just seems like he's a real real really
good guy
but let's talk about the pick kelly
let's talk about the kick
dk metcalf uh seattle's taking on that
jets defense he's at
-143 that's not bad the jets
we're talking about the jets ellie we
are talking about the jets and the jets
showed us last week
they don't care to win i know they just
fired their defensive coordinator for
that atrocious
play last week against the raiders but i
do
like this pick dk metcalf i think will
be the two
touchdown scorer for us this week i like
this pick greg
yes yes chess i like it too kelly now
let me get into the comments and see
what
they like i got jay fry he's asking if
metcalf is out
uh is metcalf out i don't think so uh
here we go we got wade0821 dk
metcalf all day he's rocking with dk
uh they're they're it's kelly it's a
parent i'm gonna just make a call i'ma
give away some hoodies but everybody's
rocking with dk
everybody it's literally like apparent
in the comments everybody's walking
rocking with dk i got sam steiner dk
baby you're walking away with a hoodie
brian royal uh d cape is a monster going
for 150
you're also walking away with a hoodie
kelly
[Music]
let's keep going because you know i'll
be here all day just i know
you're so generous let's go on to round
three who is our next challenger
next next person up we got james at
galletti and uh we're calling him
the dog whisper let's take a look at the
video
see if you see the cheese look at the
cheese look at the cheese look at the
cheese look at the cheese
look at the cheese ready look at the
cheese
all right here we go
and we're off go
go to the cheese go to the cheese go
go go go
come on
come on look come on
garbage oh my god this dog's
come on go to the cheese
go come on
look i'm gonna kill this dog
gizmo look at the cheese
go look
come on he's coming come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh oh my gosh kelly this guy
needs to tap
in with cesar milan the real dog
whisperer who can actually help him out
and get his dog
uh to obey his commands but what's up
with my guy
feeding his dog cheese like is that is
that a thing like we have a cheese thing
on the show it seems like everybody
wants to feed their animal cheese maybe
the dog
is like a vegan or something and doesn't
like cheese
ah yeah i mean i don't it seems like he
didn't like the cheese anyway let's talk
about the pig
james robinson uh the jacksonville
jaguars is taking on them tennessee
titans kelly
uh do you see him getting in the end
zone
i do i took the jags plus seven and a
half now
we all know i love those divisional home
dogs and we know
that the last time the jags were a
divisional home dog
to the colts they won the game out right
now that was
14 weeks ago i get it but i do think
that they keep it close
they've showed us over the last couple
of weeks they want to win they've been
covering spreads and i think
that james robinson does get into the
end zone so i like this pick here greg
you like the pick you like the pick i
like it too kelly i'm not gonna lie i do
like it too i just don't know about dk
metcalf though dk has been balling
but let me get into these comments and
see what
they are talking about uh i got robinson
is a lock for the team jayfry 1414
uh ryan is saying metcap is easy ryan a
bedelia both of you guys are walking
away with a hoodie kelly they're back
and forth
in the comments uh the next one next one
i'm just gonna choose
and i'm gonna rock with it big mike 13
says robinson's gonna slap into the
into the end zone like a slice of cheese
like a slice of cheese big mike you're
walking away
with a hoodie um kelly
the dog whisperer james robinson
is moving on to the next round okay
all right whoever wins this next matchup
is our week 14
squad ride winner greg who's our final
challenger
kelly ending it for us today
we got anders samayal anderson
with the pool shark legend that's what
we're calling him we're calling him the
pool shark legend
let's take a look at the video and see
why
hello everyone i suppose it's time for
my weekly
touchdown anytime score of the week
this week we have grandma cook
of the minnesota vikings and
ezekiel elliott of the dallas cowboys
now
you may ask yourself how is it going to
pick to put who to put money on
well the answer to my friends is the
great game of billiards
here we go
there it is slam dunk touchdown anytime
score this week you heard it here first
skull
yo yo this guy's a hustler he i feel
like he finessed me and i ain't even
give him any money
he's a hustler cabbie kelly i wish cabby
was here i just saw him
but he's a hustler he is a hustler but
let's talk about that pig dalvin cook
i do like that sitting at minus 162.
uh that might be a lot you know that uh
that offense
in minnesota they cannot get cooking
unless
dalvin's cooking kelly talk to me do you
like this pic
dalvin uh robinson talk to me kelly
there's two things i noticed here one
did you see that jags flag in the
background
i think that's a sign greg i gotta
sprinkle a little bit on that jags money
line i think that they're gonna get the
w
today too of course dalvin cook is gonna
score a touchdown today now
last week dalvin faltered he fumbles on
the one-yard line we almost took
dalvin last week i'm so glad we didn't
but i think he's gonna come back in a
big
way this week now we know this game has
playoff implications
for the vikings if they want to get in
they have to win this game i think we're
going to see their best game
we know coach zimmer does so well as an
underdog especially against
the nfc south i i think dalvin cook wins
this game
excuse me i think dalvin cook scores
multiple touchdowns i think the vikings
have a shot to win this game i like the
vikings
plus the touchdown as well and greg that
is
my take i'm gonna tell everybody to get
in the comments tell greg
who you think this week's winner should
be and while we do that
here is my best bet
all right guys now i always remind you
not to buy into too much to what you saw
last and what did we see
on monday night we saw the pittsburgh
steelers go up 14
to nothing that is a game that they
don't lose at heinz field
very often when leading by two
touchdowns but they managed to do it but
you know what they got that monkey off
their back
that undefeated season is no more now
they're neck and neck with the kansas
city chiefs and they have to go to
buffalo
and get that w to secure home field
advantage in the playoffs
i know buffalo on the flip side monday
night looks so great against greg's
niners
but again that was a niners team new
stadium lots of things
to buy into here i think the pittsburgh
steelers will get the running game going
this week throw in mike tomlin as an
underdog 26
and 16 against the spread on the road i
like
pittsburgh plus two and a half i like
pittsburgh plus eight and a half
in a teaser and don't forget sprinkle a
little bit on that pittsburgh steelers
money line
yay yay all right greg kelly you do
i'm shocked greg never likes my best bet
but greg
all jokes aside who's the audience like
for week 14 who are we riding with to
score a touchdown
kelly do you know their back and forth
in the comments
i got a decline mcgahey saying cook's
about to kill the defense
dude's about to put up two touchdowns
and over 150 yards
he's rocking with dalvin uh rafiq you're
getting a hoodie by the way
rafiq 23 is rocking with dalvin cook
wade 08 21 says he's rocking with
robinson
and cook both to score a touchdown today
so he's sprinkling both i like that
little parley action
uh kelly one more one more and then
we're going to call it a day
je 15 says cook likes to
cook he's getting multiple touchdowns
so i'm gonna put the ipad down everybody
i everybody name i said you're walking
away with a hoodie
but i'm gonna put the ipad down kelly
because it's very apparent
it is apparent for this week's squad
ride we are
riding with dalvin cook to score a
touchdown
uh let's throw up the graphic we have to
throw up the graphic because let me
show you guys something that only
happens here you see it says -162
now let's change it let's change it
let's change it
and let's change it now it's plus 300
now now it's plus 300 that doesn't
happen anywhere else but here
on the squad ride make sure please
please make sure you tap into the br
instagram story well we will be
riding all day you guys send me your
winners send me your winners send me
your winners
but uh in the comments tell me what i'm
looking for just in the comments
okay all right greg's doing it yet again
thank you to our friends at draftkings
for that odds boost three to one on
dalvin cook good luck with your wagers
today as greg said
check out br betting social for a link
to the odds boost that is the most
important part
of the odds boost and again tap in with
br greg and rig
stories to all of our hoodie winners
thank you to everyone who commented
thank you to all of our legends
greg ivory do the damn thing wait wait
wait kelly wait
wait wait wait wait you know i can't
just get out of here
it's christmas time it's christmas time
you know you know
i gotta be generous i have to i have all
right gregory
what do you got back into the comments
be tabs winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
bathe regularly winners only please
you're walking away with a hoodie
here we go big joe i see you joe you're
walking away send joe a hoodie
kate do pearl 23 you're walking away
with it all right kelly you
should i keep going cause i can keep
going on and on and on
always keep going listen everybody wants
a hoodie i love seeing all these guys
in the videos jumping in ig wearing
their br betting hoodie
so give give away a few more before we
go all right here we go
kelly's generous cabbie would have cut
me off here we go sam steiner
you asking how do you get a hoodie
you're getting one now
here we go i got another one rafiq 23
you're walking away with hoodie true
tras you're walking away with e kelly
i'm done
all right i'm done i'm done uh-uh i'll
close this out alongside
grega claus greg ivory i'm kelly stewart
cabbie
get back to your vacation and get out of
our comments we'll see you guys next
[Music]
week
[Music]
you